you're not calling the shots I am and
whether you think my call is wrong or
not it's still my name on that goddamn
wall
[Music]
what does it look like I'm doing I'm
having lunch with a client to discuss
his investment business you don't
represent my investment business which
is exactly why we need to have lunch we
don't need to have anything because the
deal is Harvick has been cleared of
criminal charges then you get the rest
of my business I don't care what the
deal was William I care what the deal is
because now that that indictment's come
down Harvey is going to be spending all
of his time on you that's not my problem
I'm making it your problem we get all of
your business but we handle none of it
you quit you lose billables you
can't afford to lose we quit and it
looks like we realized your case was a
loser and wanted distance from it which
you can't afford really want to start a
business relationship this way
give a how it starts William
I give a how it looks
that's why I do this here
you want to look like you already
represent my firm well look at that
looks like I'm worth hiring after all
so are we actually going to talk
business or am I just going to bill you
for the pleasure of my company
I didn't overrule you on the other
I beat you Baron Square no you didn't
you're right I cheated like you
you jump to the other side you put me on
the other side I had a deal that put
your name right next to mine
and it wasn't even up there yet and you
started acting like it was on top of
mine to protect you this wasn't
about protecting me this was about
advancing you that's what this whole
thing is about what apartment said it I
didn't think it was true he said you
don't trust me
he meant
you're afraid of me afraid of you
boy I just kicked your ass and you
didn't just want it you begged me for it
so now you're going to stay here
be humble
and learn your goddamn place
well
this should be fun
we've never been across the aisle from
each other which is why you don't
realize that it won't be fun we'll see
what we see
look at that game time
ladies first ladies first
son of a for being polite were you
being polite when you hired me what does
one have to do with the other to the man
who hired me
for all you've done
do you want to know what I meant when I
wrote that card
the day you made me that offer I asked
you did it have anything to do with
gender or race you swore it didn't you
lied to me
it didn't you're lying now
but Daniel Hardman may have used people
but he didn't give a about their
gender or their color he showed you the
list right next to my name an asterisk
not law review not second in my class
diversity you were treated the same you
tell yourself that but we both know the
truth
which is why I sleep at night just fine
well it doesn't change the facts in this
case does it
no no it doesn't but this will Charles
you remember Lewis lit sorry I couldn't
run Dr wanted me to take it easy hey
Charles
great to see you
you told me that story to stall
that was a stall
but this is for me
when I saw that asterisk next to my name
it made me sick to my stomach
because in one second I understood how
you will always see me
so that card was a thank you
because if I hadn't felt sick then I
might not have worked as hard as I did
to get where I am today
you woke the dragon Charles
how do you like me now
Louis you got everything you wanted and
you are done taking it out on him
because no matter what you do I'm not
letting him quit then I'll just fire him
you can't I can and I will because
Jessica would rather he be fired than
you all go to jail no one's going to
jail see she knows what's what I signed
the agreement he's done and then I hire
Katrina back as my associate and that's
not going to happen
what are you talking about Louis I'm
afraid you've made your last dictate to
me his name partner I'm not gonna let
you take this away from me I'm not
taking anything away from you you are
still named partner right after you sang
this
I added a little something extra after
you finished drafting it this says I'm
co-conspirator hiring a fraud you are
you became one the second you used him
to get your name on the door I know I'm
not a real lawyer but that sounds like
he is to me I am a real lawyer he is
I'm not signing it Louis here's the
thing I told you not to tell anybody
about this and then you went and you
shouted it to Robert Zane and then you
made me tell the partners and the Capper
is there are about a hundred people
waiting to greet you after the unveiling
you arranged which won't happen if you
don't sign that
[Music]
that yeah you could but you won't
because you use that little secret to
get where you are right now
it was the only bullet in your chamber
I am taking your gun away
set me up you set yourself up just like
you did with Charles forsman and what I
learned from him was once you get
something that you want you will do
whatever it takes to keep it
I had inside
so that we can get out to your goddamn
party
[Music]
this isn't
a coincidental encounter is it no it is
not
you were having lunch with Jeff Malone
today
come on Jessica you bang to release you
could do is take him for lunch that was
not funny
wait a second you want me to take him to
lunch because you banged him Harvey
to go ahead and say banged to my face
one more time
I'm not going to but not because I'm
scared of you
whatever lets you sleep at night white
boy
Jessica
Edward Daniel haven't seen you since
that business in Milan beautiful weather
oh enough we are not friendly
adversaries Daniel and you're about to
lose my client already said no but he
may no longer listen to you when I
inform him of your prior embezzlement
you told him I didn't tell him anything
I found it on my own
Edward and I are merging I had to show
him the books legally required to show
me her books and unlike you I don't
break the law the fact that Hanley
Folsom could be made acutely aware of
you do break the law Jessica not
reporting embezzlement is a crime
why don't you bring that up at your
sentencing hearing why don't I sue you
you could
anybody could sue anybody but you still
don't have proof that I told him and our
firms combined have 10 times the
resources that yours
oh wait you don't have a firm you're
just here living in Zane's offices
working on those cases that will no
longer be yours when we're done with you
goodbye Daniel
oh
get your client to sign those papers
will you
[Music]
Mr Forrest
so many lives were ruined that night
your daughters her boyfriends
yours is there a question someone had to
pay for that didn't they yeah they sure
as hell did is that why you paid for
Maria Gomez to go to rehab to keep her
from testifying at Mr Bailey's trial
what objection your honor she's putting
the victim on trial my client is the
victim here Ms Pearson you better back
this up fast then ask the witness to
answer my question I never even heard of
that woman until yesterday your honor
the defense would like to admit into
evidence the admissions form for an
Allison Dobson into the pathways
rehabilitation center from 12 years ago
who was that she was Maria Gomez's
roommate and I'm gonna put her on the
stand no there can't be no you can't do
that she's going to say that Maria told
her that she felt terrible about
abandoning her rejection hearsay no she
won't overruled and she's going to
testify that you paid for Maria to be
there I had nothing to do with anything
that's not what she's going to say I
don't care she's lying why would she lie
she just wants to put the record
straight the record is straight not
according to her roommate she's lying
objection badgering how could you know
because Maria Gomez didn't have a
roommate
what did you just say
I paid for her because she's a junkie
who'd say anything to get him out of
what he did so I got her out of the way
because he did it Mr Forest he did it
your honor
the defense asked that Mr Bailey be
exonerated
and his sentence be commuted immediately
Mr Marsden
we have no objections your honor then
the jury may be excused and Mr Bailey
you're free
I can't believe it we did it
[Music]
I can't
thank you enough
you don't have to thank me Leonard
to walk out that door
[Music]
I'm a little busy right now oh whatever
it is put it to the side Daniel wants
you to work with Lewis on the reinsdorf
case
you got something to say Harvey say it
okay I'll say it you didn't have my back
when Hartman screwed me over and now
you're carrying his water while he tries
to humiliate me I don't care what he's
doing I care about what I'm doing which
is to see if you can put that ego of
yours aside and play the long game what
the hell are you talking about do you
have any idea how many times I had to
smile and take it when Charles Van Dyke
pawned his work off on me or when
Stanley Gordon would call me into his
office just so he can Ogle my ass when I
left that is not the same thing not to
mention when Schmidt would talk about
the blacks like he was living in 1950.
did up for years Harvey
now it's your turn what if I won't then
you're not my guy because if you can't
even pretend to bend in need of your
Rivals it doesn't matter what you do to
get ahead of them in the future
they're gonna see you coming a mile away
we're going to talk about what happened
not tonight Jessica I'll call me
better and baron he did call you that
but it's only going to get worse and you
should have jumped to my defense sooner
than you did I'm your lawyer not your
husband and if I didn't jump in when I
did we'd be broke look I told you before
we need to settle and I told you before
we're not settling don't you see what
he's doing he's trying to make this case
about gender it's not it doesn't matter
look you can't be the name defendant on
a gender discrimination case well we're
suing Folsom foods for the same thing
relating to that man then you're going
to look like a fool that's enough
calling the shots I am and whether you
think was wrong or not it is still my
name on that goddamn wall
but it's not my firm anymore
it's yours what do you mean hours I mean
I've decided to step down what Jessica
listen somewhere along the way I forgot
why I became a lawyer in the first place
and it wasn't just a fight for money and
power it was to fight for something more
you're not fighting for
something more you're running away Lewis
no we bust our asses save this goddamn
place she decides to up and leave we
committed to this Louis she isn't doing
this to you she's doing it for herself I
don't give a why she's doing it
it's selfish and self-serving and it's
not gonna happen do you think I want a
goddamn do this
I have to do this you can't just roll
this all away after we gave everything
to save it that's enough
Louis after the partners left we swore
we were going to dedicate every ounce of
Blood Sweat and Tears we had to this
place
but we didn't
Harvey and I focused on getting Mike out
Jessica and Rachel focused on Leonard
Bailey and you focused on finding love
in your life
that's not true yes it is
[Music]
no one's saying you have to give up the
firm Lewis
[Music]
oh
you just have to let me go
about this
tell you the truth
for the first time in my life
I'm not sure about anything and it
scares the out of me
but I'm sure I have to do this
[Music]
to Pearson Spector
Fierce inspector
[Music]